hey little
i'm talking to you directly
i'm coming on tour and i don't always do
it so you got to come see me and here we
go april 15th and 16th i will be in
louisville and evansville april 23rd and
24th i will be in tulsa and oklahoma
city beacon theater new york city first
time may 14th there's going to be some
surprise guests there and that's all i
could say but you do not want to miss
that and i'm going out west cali i'm
finally coming to you i'm going to be in
san diego on may 21st and at the wilton
theater in los angeles for the first
time ever on may 22nd everything is
available right now at
savolcanocomedy.com you little bit
this friday march 25th the win las vegas
baby we're going to be there tt jerry's
coming on stage april 8th the egyptian
room at the old national center in
indianapolis indiana april 9th denver
colorado april 16th wall street theater
norwalk connecticut april 29th wind
creek event center in pennsylvania
christy comedy.com for all the tiki
wikis thank you guys we'll see you at
the
[Music]
be afraid show be ashamed don't hesitate
to say hey babe hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey and uh we'll do elvis
for hey babe and then we'll do um hey
i'm hey babe let me just go right into
it all right all right so it's like
she's a girl she loves martial she's in
america too she's a girl she creates
about hey babe loves horses and a
boyfriend too now hey hey baby now hey
hey baby don't start why just use that
what just just use what you just did
yeah no no just that was it
no
i got it you know that's way better for
people to see like how the sausage is
made
all right okay
we'll play your way
ready yeah she's a good girl
she loves her mama
loves jesus
in america too
she's a good
girl
she's crazy
babe loves horses
and a boyfriend too
now come here
hey baby
now hey
[Applause]
yes babe we do yes we do you guys have a
lot of rituals yeah well we have that's
definitely one of them yeah but i will
say i do want to give a shout out real
quick to tom brady who is coming back
out of retirement yeah he said he was
the time he's coming back now tom brady
won the super bowl two years ago uh
oldest guy in the nfl 43 he wanted that
and it was in tampa bay which was
astounding uh now the people he played
with the kansas city chiefs and i just
want to give a shout out to them i'd be
remiss to fight it and patrick mahomes
uh because they're a good ball club and
they got a bright future ahead of them
and uh and then of course you know this
year you had you know joe barrow took a
loss with the bengals you're stacking
two rituals yeah yeah and then the
seahawks won
and uh and
it was like a ritual and
they just want to give a shout out to
the who who won with the
seahawks the homes no rituals
i don't know sports at all all right
well it's fun i get it brady's had her
time it was worth mentioning
what do you do you guys judge his
retirement flip-flop it was like two
weeks it's wild actually i don't i don't
that's what walt says he's like it was a
he walt's position uh well flanagan his
position was that he was doing it to
force them to allow he didn't want to
play for the buccaneers so he was like
well [ __ ] you guys i'll just retire if
you don't let me play where i want
and his theory is that they stay held
firm they're like well then [ __ ]
retire
oh oh so you're saying brady's back
because the buck's called his bluff
well they wouldn't let him out of a
contract right right oh i don't i i
wasn't sure of his contract situation i
thought his contract was up
retirement as like uh yeah
well well even uh even aaron rodgers
went back to uh
i think you i know you don't but he went
back to the green bay packers when he he
was going to be he was looking around
was a steelers might have got him we
don't know what we're doing right now we
got a backup quarterback from
let's not get into it
i don't watch football so another you
know i get lost
welcome our very special guest today
brian quinn
uh chris christie d's under the weather
brian is uh
his
notable affable loyal
replacement all the time now i'm affable
yeah the unofficial mascot of no presh
don't take it i'll take it
i'm no press
yeah i'm actually no pressure check out
the taste buds uh painting we got from
his fan that joe is of rook assault oh
it's great they really captured the
[ __ ]
grumpy sad sack
look on his face
we did it we did a few a few pods
yesterday and therefore he was very
salty so he changed a bit right
we realized that we weren't fighting
enough lately
we didn't know what it was like i guess
i was like
sorry no no please just what is he gonna
do when he meets someone and falls in
love and like finds that his life isn't
just a misery pit 24 hours a day well
that's yet to happen so
i think he'll find female derozan though
oh really oh
isn't that like lightning
that's tough they would just nitpick
everything
no it's so funny that you called it a
misery pit because he had this ditch he
used to stare into when he was a kid
there was a ditch by his house and he
had no friends and he used to go sit in
the ditch and look he's just gonna sit
at the top of the ditch and look into it
for real and so now we call it his like
said ditch oh so the misery pit was like
i love like you know that famous quote
like when you stare into the abyss the
abyss stares back yeah i wonder if the
pit stared back exactly the pit was like
why the [ __ ] is this kid coming here
every day bringing me down with this
[ __ ] what did somebody fill me in
the reverse of it
pennywise hangs himself in the [ __ ]
sewers
what was he picked on as a kid no like i
don't know all of a sudden one day
jerosa just derosie just comes out with
these things that you like blow your
mind like he never talked about that one
day he was like there was a ditch by my
house like was it construction or it was
just a ditch in pennsylvania
and he's like and i spent most of my
time in and around the ditch alone and
then his parents said as a child he ate
oysters and clams the most
[Laughter]
they said they said
they told a story about how he made them
he made them he made them drive him
around in search of surf and turf at a
young age
what did they later say that was recent
i don't know i got confused you've
brought so many people to my life you
really have
but he's a g he's special man
yeah so what i was saying was uh what
was i just laying around oh so we we
lately like like there was like a lack
of us like really going at it
we used to be much more and i was like
is it because
we've like are there's ebbs and flows
and we've hit a a string of items that
maybe we are
not that passionate about or the other
guy is not saying anything that's really
getting under our skin and we realized
that like he started this no matter what
happens i love you chance yeah
and he wanted to defuse things with that
by starting with that because we had
such bad fights that he would go home
and keep them with him so when we
started that it actually worked and we
started fighting less so he so a couple
days ago yesterday came in and he goes
we're going to change the chant for a
little while so it's time to get salty
it's time to get salty it's time to get
salty and then the second we're done we
say it one time as soon as we say it
three times the first time he has to
insult me any way he chooses immediately
after that and then we go it's time and
he has he has 30 seconds to insult me
and then and then right after that we go
it's time to get salty it's time to get
salty it's time to get salty and then i
insult him for 30 seconds and the way
that the time is up is that v
v who i don't think you know
who works with us and pimp had pots and
pans yesterday like
and they would bang the pots and pans
after 30 seconds and then we'd literally
go right into the battle and we had
three brawls yesterday uh all right
was hating on the no shoe policy in this
household
look
here's the thing i don't like it
i get it that was his first insult to me
he was like i hate you stupid no shoes
policy we all hate it yeah we i don't
hate it i i get it my plan my problem is
i have the the planar fish so every time
i come to your house it's a countdown to
the pain
i i live with that as well i have five
feet so what you just inflicted on
everybody else well no my thing is like
no no i i actually have uh
slippers downstairs for guests that's
that's well my thing is like
because i feel bad if someone doesn't
expect it they take off their shoe and
there's a hole in this sock or that's
like a bowling alley now he's wearing
somebody else's slippers all night like
i spray it down but but you're you're
look you're my best friend right in the
world so it's like i feel
entirely comfortable being like look i'm
just gonna leave slippers here oh yeah
yeah that's what i mean so people do
that yeah
i've come here with slippers
okay can i only wear crocs when i come
here now yes because they slip right off
at the door so that is very freeing to
know i can go out without with crocs on
and i'm not going to get judged well you
know but you don't wear do you wear
shoes in your house
no but but people but i don't when guest
comes in i don't i don't say oh really
yeah i don't know but you have clothes
you have area rugs you have you know i
don't know man i just feel like
i don't understand the people that don't
take their shoes off
think about wait like and on a given day
i'm coming from an airport let's say
yeah i go in the airport i piss before i
leave
i walk in a public restroom yeah and i
walk through the parking lot and i walk
you know wherever the [ __ ] i walk and
then just walk right into
my own kitchen my own living room i mean
obviously if i stood in a puddle of piss
and my shoes were soaked i would
obviously i'd probably throw the shoes
out but i just figured the walk from the
through the parking lots probably
eradicate like should they depart but i
think whatever's on the bottom of all of
our shoes is always mostly always on the
bottom of that traces of it
and i and i do believe that most of us
go into public restrooms
more fairly
frequently you're not going to train the
train is a public relationship so you're
on the train right you're walking in the
subway on the subway floors and on a new
york city street there's [ __ ] pissed
[ __ ] but how far do you take it
like you i have a friend my friend kim
she won't
she comes home from work she changes
she's like i don't even want the clothes
that's what there that's what uh my lady
insists on all the time so you come home
and you change well i don't wear outside
clothes like in the bed well nobody does
that right yeah like but if you're tired
like i won't come in in my outfit i will
just plop down on the bed to rest over
the covers or anything like that oh i'll
do that no like we weren't even like we
don't even want to wear the outside
clothes especially coming off like a
plane and stuff planes forget about it
yeah planes are a whole i just take it
all off but you know like but but if
people do have that then
i mean they're fooling themselves that
they don't think that
they're they're they're basically in
infecting their entire floor in the
house then you walk on it with your
socks and then you think it's different
and then all of a sudden you jump into
bed with socks on you but you know i see
you in the ocean dude all the time like
if you take ocean water and look at it
it's like teeming with germs and life is
it really yeah i think it's just like
you know
yeah but but yeah but you're getting it
in your mouth and and yeah okay you're
you're beard you're getting living
creatures in your i'm just saying i
don't look i i get it i'm not gonna
derose and argue this to the death
because i understand that i get it but i
just think it's wild for those who don't
do it i wonder what the norm is
you throw up a poll right now like is
your how am i going to put up a poll
is your house a shoes off house or not
yes or no what do you guys think about
people that eat on the subway cause i've
been watching that go down now since
look man my dad drove so i know subways
my dad was a subway car driver they are
absolutely horrendous that being said i
can eat a hot dog on a subway oh really
yeah who gives a [ __ ] i mean i'm not
gonna put it down on the seat next to me
and and eat from there but if like
there's a hot dog stand that i'm running
to make a train like i'm not gonna be
like i i gotta do it i i don't know
oddly specific situation
well you said eat on a train so i
just not gonna take a date on a train
and like get a five-course meal like
driving around but i wouldn't eat a
sandwich but that's what happened i bet
some romantic hipster oh my god one year
uh when i was young i was like 18 or so
for like a um a valentine's day thing me
and my girl at the time just took stan
island ferry over to a mcdonald's
downtown manhattan at mcdonald's and
took it back and you know it was nice
i've eaten on the ferry yeah yeah very
very nice the ferry's awesome yeah the
subway is becoming more and more odd
that's your friend de blasio man [ __ ]
ruined the city
that way
he [ __ ] drove this city into the
ground i mean he was a [ __ ] monster
it's so funny you tell you say that to
anybody it's so funny like my friend
i'll put you on the defensive
immediately
yeah i'm gonna miss when we can't blame
him in like four or five years uh yeah i
hope we i hope we can't blame him
because like
he did that man of a job that everybody
dislikes him or is that just a joke no
no he did his own party alike dude he
i mean i know i i know what i know i've
had i i wonder if like the deep root of
hatred is deserved or not i mean it's
deep rooted hatred i don't hate the guy
i think you i think you
know but i feel like a lot of people
have seen standing ovations as that de
blasio's the punchline he's
okay but
it's a fun phonetic word it's fun it's
it's just fun to like it works on
multiple levels because he didn't do a
job that people don't service and it's
fun to be like de blasio but you hear it
no matter who's in office you'll always
hear the name [ __ ]
that's because of
giuliani
bloomberg bloomberg i guess he was
fairly neutral
once he killed the sodas i heard that
non-stop and cool yeah but they got on
bloomer's case sure you're the mayor
you're always gonna be but i don't think
yeah you're right
he was much more in a neutral pocket i
think he helped the city a lot he helped
the city because he ran new york city
like a business which is what you have
to do it is interesting though de blasio
chose the name de blasio his real name
is like totally oh i didn't even know
that so it is a fun word to say maybe
that's why he chose it why would he
choose de blasio doesn't that mean like
of like why would you want blah in your
face
mayor de blasio the mayor of blah town
i i had uh lunch once with the staten
island borough president or the expert
president and he he knows de blasio and
he swore he goes if you met him
you would love him he's like he just
doesn't know how to he's like he's so
nice he's so personable like he like you
do like him he's like but his policies
are just all you can't get more wrong
headed like i mean the guy i don't know
how
i couldn't believe he got elected a
second time i i that's when i was i gave
up on politics i was like this [ __ ]
guy you've i don't remember who's voted
running against him so maybe maybe
that's yeah but
i couldn't wait for him to leave
but you think he's the reason that uh
he's a reason no good i know they are of
course
what happens you stop enforcing [ __ ]
any crimes like what do you think is
going to happen
yeah that's exactly what's going to
happen yeah like you were like
i think covent had a lot to do with the
subway it was like that before cohen it
was yeah it was
started all right so like i have friends
in the sanitation department i'm sure
your dad would speak to this so like
yeah i i was driving around manhattan
this before coveted and i was like what
is with the piles of garbage [ __ ]
every
first thing i noticed was the frozen
piss you remember that winter like five
years ago frozen piss when he
decriminalized peeing in public oh yeah
yeah i would walk in manhattan and it
would just in the winter people would
pee on the walls and it would piss could
freeze oh yeah and it was just a piss
comes out at 98 degrees doesn't it but
if it's
[ __ ] 20 degrees out and it just stays
there it's like it's like literally like
like like uh like yellow ice it's not
yellow but it's like it starts on the
wall and it comes down and i remember
our old office on broad street i would i
would walk to it from the ferry and be
like i cannot believe how much frozen
that was meant to be like an emergency
situation type nod right not like
everyone just stopped pissing no it
wasn't it was meant to decriminalize it
because
his point of view was like look like if
you like you're making all these things
that people have to do
um a crime and it's like it's only
affecting poor people it's not affecting
rich people so we're gonna decriminalize
it
to make life easier on on i guess the
poor people
and you're just like but wait but poor
people have to live in pitt streets too
like i don't understand what you mean
like what is everything for him was the
haves and have-nots it was this tale of
two cities isn't that why the plague
spread like back in the day everyone's
just sleeping and pissed
sounds true i don't know i i don't i
also don't know enough about politics
i'm talking like i know what the [ __ ]
i'm talking about i know i don't really
know anything i i just know i i just
know that he was a reason like he cut
back the garbage delivery and stuff like
uh pickup and stuff like that it's it's
weird every few years is a guy who's so
fun to hate and i don't know why yeah
well no he
i felt he [ __ ] up the city a lot de
blasio i i do but what are you gonna do
so it's a misdemeanor it says to piss in
public was that old piping
to be convicted of this offense means
you would have to have a criminal record
is that what a misdemeanor means that if
mr mean is not trouble unless you
already had a criminal record before it
i don't know
i i don't know i don't know any of this
[ __ ]
missy misdemeanor elliot
yeah a minor a minor wrongdoing
uh
if that's all it means and you could say
someone's doing a misdemeanor any time
it's not necessarily it doesn't say like
always in relation to like actual law i
guess it's like a super minor crime i
guess partnership with less than 12
months in prison or in jail misdemeanor
that sounds i mean
11 months in prison doesn't sound like a
misdemeanor no i don't i don't think
you'd get that tonight i like atoms you
guys like atoms so i like adams
yeah still feeling that i kind of want
to get a drink with him yeah i'm still
feeling that he seems like a cool guy
yeah that's for sure i saw him with a
fedora and he looked very he looked very
fashionable yeah yeah all right
i'll have to invite him on oh man he'd
probably do something fun like that he's
i like him
you know my friend got arrested for not
arrested he got a summons in new jersey
for peeing one night after we went we
were walking from a bar
back to like a
speech house you got a ticket yeah you
got ticketed two of them
one kid i went to college with he peed
in a school zone and they charged him as
a pedophile
that's a trumped-up charge
well it's also the same as like when
little kids in high school send each
other photos if they get caught that's
that's cp you can't
but even if they're little kids already
yeah wait i don't mean like graphic
images i just you mean like if two kids
are 16. anything that you might not want
to be
like in position right but i don't mean
in the most most cynical way like you
mean like a young relationship even if
it's like yeah healthy for adults
what happens with that like what happens
if a girl let's say is dating a guy and
they're a year apart
i think and then one becomes even i
think there's there's uh there's like
clauses and laws yeah because if you
think it has to be because if you think
about it nobody's the same age so any
relationship coming out from younger or
older is going to fall into the the
effects of that i remember a few years
ago like there was this crazy story on
the local news like on fox 5 that all
these connecticut kids got charged
because they they like one girl was
dating a guy send him a photo send
another guy photo and then they spread
it around their friend groups and they
all were in possession
and it circulated and it hit the news
and i was like that's a thing i never
thought of
oh i think i might have remembered this
like
maybe like 10 years ago or something
like six years ago okay i remember one a
while back too with that exact thing
like
someone sent out one pick and it spread
around the whole school and then
everyone got in like a ton of trouble
it's so confusing because they're doing
that and then they're making the kids
watch you for you
right what do you want i haven't watched
you for it but i heard it's like wild
yeah i can't my little sister watches i
don't i don't know i heard my nieces
watch it i'm so upset with that i'm
embarrassed to say that i've seen the
graphic right is it i don't i i from i
heard from
here
that oh god our nieces are watching this
feels like degrassi with sex scenes oh
really yeah okay with zendaya does
sex scenes apparently i don't i'm not
watching it she's on euphoria yeah she's
illegal oh wow yeah i'm surprised by
that i i talked to me about uh have you
heard of this show uh emily in paris
why have i heard of that i have heard of
it who told me about that
what's up everybody let's talk lucy uh
for a second look we're all adults here
and i know some of us choose to use
nicotine to relax focus or just unwind
after a long day i mean we could all
agree that's no surprise lucy is a
modern oral nicotine company that makes
nicotine gum lozenges pouches for adults
who are looking for the best most
responsible way to consume their
nicotine it's a new year kinda we're in
now we're getting approaching spring now
it's gonna be a new season why not start
the new season by switching to a new
nicotine product that you can feel good
about if you're already a nicotine user
i actually want to give it to one of my
family members who will remain nameless
because i would rather they use
lucy
than smoke the way they do and
if that's you know if that's if i can
get them to try something new why not uh
if you enjoy using nicotine you should
definitely check out lucy's products at
lucy.co.comco that's lucy.co and use
promo code babe at checkout also i have
to read this disclaimer warning this
product contains nicotine nicotine is an
addictive chemical remember if you're
interested in a better way to use
nicotine visit lucy.co and be sure to
use that promo code
babe
what is that sound babes it's the sound
of another sale on shopify the
all-in-one commerce platform to start
run and grow your business okay shopify
gives entrepreneurs the resources
once reserved for big business so
upstart startups and established
businesses alike can sell everywhere
synchronize online and in-person sales
and effortlessly stay informed scaling
your business is a journey of endless
possibility believe me this podcast
started out
selling merch recently and we're not
stopping there we are going to evolve
this plan and we are going to use
shopify to uh
i think i really want chris is not here
right now but i'm going to talk to him
about what we can do to actually use
everything that they have to offer like
the old hey babe shopify powers millions
of businesses from first sale to full
scale uh reach out to customers online
and across social networks with an
ever-growing suite of channel
integrations and apps including facebook
instagram tick tock pinterest integrated
into all those synchronize your online
and in-person sales
gain insights as you grow with detailed
reporting of conversion rates profit
margins and beyond that is one of the
most important things you can do for
your business if you're not keeping
track of those types of things you do
not know how you're scaling you do not
know who you're growing you don't know
what kind of profit you're turning over
i was a small business owner in my life
and i had to learn that and i learned it
the hard way and
look more than a store shopify grows
with you
go to shopify.com slash hey babe all
lowercase
for a free 14-day trial and get full
access to everything that shopify has
their entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com
hey babe again hey babe is all lowercase
right now shopify.com hey babe
who told me about that i don't know i
have heard of it so this is so yeah okay
so this is emily in paris and
okay no this is all right no we might
get flagged for the music oh okay so
oh darren star made it that makes so
much sense that's phil collins daughter
by the way oh emily yeah emma the emily
is is her last name's collins it's phil
collins
um and
all i kept hearing about the show
because it won a bunch of awards and was
pissing people off because they were
like how is something so slight winning
all these awards
you know and look you could look at this
and you're and you're like this is not
something brian quinn will have a watch
and then the other day i was walking
through my living room and it was on all
right and you don't say you got sucked
in it was the seventh episode of emily
in paris i don't even know how i ended
up kidding me dude so i sat down no i
can't even i'm watching and i'm like no
way i'm telling you i started watching
the seventh episode of emily in paris
and before the episode was over i was
like well what happens and then i
started watching the next episode and
before i i
with no sound
wait was that lady nude yeah no it's
like it's like a disney fight it's not
disney
it's a disney fied sex in the city like
dude like there's a there's oh no
without words i'm like no way what is it
that is awarding to you
it is funnier than it should be okay
and it knows what it is but funny for
the good viewers
uh no funny legitimately funny like that
guy with the guy that left there with
the hair yeah uh
is uh really funny on the show and that
guy is awesome like the guy people she
works with are really funny and then
it's like
it's so like
like i didn't even finish this episode
right but like she was running this big
party she's running this big party
okay and she had a movie running it what
is it what is her she's like uh i'm not
even clear because i only started on the
seventh episode
i haven't even gone back yet but i fully
intend to go back and watch all of that
in paris and the closer to die for so
so she she finally gets a big break and
she i guess she's like an event planner
and she's running this she's running oh
she's not a child
no she goes oh it looks like she's a
child no she's almost like emily in the
big city like home alone too no she
moves from chicago to paris for her
dream job this is what everyday was a
pickup okay and uh and she's having all
these adventures in paris and they shoot
it in paris so it looks great and the
fashion's all like on point and um since
when
in your life
have you ever said
the fashion's really good the fashion
point what are you talking about i'm
talking about i never have heard you
mention fashion in our lives on point i
love him
why do you have a fashion opinion he's
having a renaissance because i'm
watching everyone in paris
you're appreciating the fashion loving
it since you win
that's wild dude
i'm telling you i'm i can't even
understand these words coming out of
your mouth never has he ever spoken
commented on spoken about canada alluded
to anything having to do it's fashion
any time in our entire lives yeah i'm
into it now i'm like i watch the outfits
they wear and i'm like wow who makes
that like i'm like how is it it's so
fashion forward that it's actually
catching your eye yes yeah okay they
they look like they're dressed in candy
you're just like it looks amazing that
feels like sex in the city i think right
but it's it's it's not as like you know
sex in the city was like you know it was
his own beast this is a little more like
i don't know man like i was kind of
getting into it so wait wait so she got
the the ability to run this party right
and like there was a celebrity there and
she's wearing a two million dollar watch
on the red carpet
and
like i don't know what happens but it's
this type of show where she's comedy
it's funny it's funny it's like a and
and like so she i don't think it's a
comedy but they weave in it so she
someone comes up to with a clipboard
because now she's in charge and it's
just like you just need to sign here and
she's signing and they should they're
like well what for what she's like
what's this for she's like oh it's it's
it's insurance somebody's gotta sign for
the insurance for the watch right and
walks away now it's a type of show where
i haven't seen what happens yet but i
can't only imagine that she's going to
look for the watch she's on the hook for
two and a half but it's also the type of
show where at the end of the show
she'll have solved
like it'll be two she'll owe 2.5 million
for the episode and by the end it'll be
washed out in some way oh really yeah
see look at the fashion
[Laughter]
you're telling me you don't notice these
outfits look at louis yeah i think it's
very apparent that they want you to yeah
well they got paris it's emily in paris
yeah emily every single outfit now that
you say every single one was like oh wow
there you go it would be amazing to see
you two at fashion week in new york i
would go i'd [ __ ] do it my god you
have to go i would do you have to go so
i you wouldn't tell from me but uh i'm
into fashion i like fashion
i i don't represent it on this podcast
or really on television
but i do i have clothes downstairs that
i wish i could wear but i don't wear
them and i have a little handle on
everything you're saying yeah but it's
also like when i'm at like my goal
weight i get more fashionable okay when
i'm like at night at my goal weight it's
more like athleisure and t-shirts and
stuff like getting through life yeah but
my goal weight haven't been in a couple
years my goal weight of 155.
i yeah i can't look man i mean i'm this
emily in paris
i was 155 and as a sophomore and i was
high school
i threw that out go way under and i'm
actually i'm very delighted that none of
you laughed at it well i support your
dreams yeah oh yeah look at that that's
an ascot who's the guy on the right he
looks familiar is that little nas x i
don't think it's a little nasa is that
jared
carmichael
he's super he's fun like these two guys
like though that's our boss and that
they work with those two they're that
whole office staff is excellent jose
leaderman in the back it does i wish
do you know oh you know i'm sorry about
any letterman oh no no no no
oh okay annie dude you talk to any
anything yeah she's doing well she's
awesome yeah she's out in la for forever
i i was always a big fan yeah yeah she's
good um
what was i gonna say all right so i i
have something similar right so all of a
sudden out of nowhere like a year ago
from all angles people would tell me to
watch a certain show on netflix and it
came originally from my nieces so i was
suspect
but then i heard friends talking about
it and then my dad is like oh you gotta
watch it i watch the whole thing and and
then
she her friends mentioned it
and
it was called outer banks
yeah and
it looked like this immediately upon
looking it looked for me like not for me
okay cheesy it's like teen angsty kind
of like murder mystery not murder
mystery but like it's a thriller it's
like a thriller series but it's of like
you know maybe teens 20 year olds
and it's
it
again you could look at it and see
exactly what it is right away and i'm
like i don't think this is gonna it
almost plays to me like um
like a like a like a network nighttime
soap
yeah or something like that i don't know
how to describe it but you know it's a
team [ __ ] you know i mean it looks like
you know it's like action one tree hill
yes okay
uh and apparently there's like you know
there's a mysterious death and someone
doesn't know who did it it might be i
don't know because i only watched the
first few episodes yeah but i watched it
and i was like yeah it's all right but
it's like at the end of the day it's
like it feels very like dawson's
creakish to me and if you don't like
dawson's creek then then it's gonna be i
watch a few episodes i'm like all right
all right but then i was like yeah but
still it's kind of like corny a little
bit still do you
[Music]
but everyone raved about it about it
you could see with the no words you know
what it is yeah
teen movies like part of me feels like
if it didn't have the netflix logo no
one would ever swear by it
right oh really really you think netflix
i i thought people were like rebelling
against netflix because they keep
dropping the ball on things well this is
what's going up it's 20 now i know this
was like came out a couple of years ago
and i think there's a few couple of
seasons so even maybe more than that
what i think happens is
if you put something on netflix
eventually people are going to click on
it and it's going to f like they're like
i need something new to watch oh here's
a new show let's watch it you know so it
kind of like it is funny though dad
watches this yeah i know
my dad does watch a lot of tv and it was
also pandemic oh yeah so like he was
going through series like crazy but my
dad gets hooked with any little little
like cliffhanging stuff would he watch
emily in paris and let me know what he
thinks
you know now i i think i remember when i
hearing this i think jim gaffigan maybe
told me that
told me he said that uh maybe emily and
paris because it's ringing a bell where
like they were like his family was
watching it his kids or whatever and he
was like no way and then he sat down and
he was immediately hooked he said and it
was one of those shows and i think it
might have been emily it could be dude i
don't even know how like i think you
know netflix will just auto start that i
don't see it like i think it just went
and and i was i dude i was you
oh
i got a show i got a new show to talk
about continue no i was gonna say i was
you two weeks ago yeah i was like emily
in paris i'm not watching this and now
let me ask you a question i'm trying to
find time to walk are you high
am i high right now you know when you're
watching me uh
no i don't okay so it's a real
assessment then it's not a high
assessment it's it's i know what i'm
saying i i understand
how is this not uh right under like uh
you know on the on the afi's yeah you
know like this is citizen kane and then
lego movie right and then
like then i'll come too
and i'll always be like i'll i'll never
go back and watch it i'm like i always
wonder if that movie is as amazing as i
thought it was because i was high what
movies are uh are you ashamed that you
love
oh
like overall over my life like uh one
that you'd keep secret you'd want to
keep secret that you love it
well
you know what i probably watched uh
william hurts lost in space more than it
should have been life isn't that funny
like i always like i don't even know if
i've seen that and he just passed right
he just passed that's what made me think
of because shout out bill
uh not not the series he made a version
of the movie back in the day
uh it's hur
oh yeah hers is that's like the bad guy
on deadwood
right william hurt
oh hurt yeah oh it's hurt yeah okay so
98 i saw this in theaters and every few
years i'll just rewatch it it's not a
good movie i don't even know if i've
heard of it but wow
but i'll watch it every few years and
i'll be like all right i don't know it's
like this weird thing at all yeah it's
not that great what do you love about it
dude i don't know i think i just it's
familiar to me so every few years i'll
just watch it yeah yeah i'm trying to
think of like what i i don't really know
because if i don't
what movie do i like that's a guilty
pleasure mine is gremlins too
gremlins is a guilty pleasure that's a
[ __ ] straight-up great movie oh you
know what attack of the killer tomatoes
too okay all right but that i don't know
what it's meant to be it's meant to be
bad yeah do you think gremlins 2 is a
guilty pleasure i think so yeah oh i
think it's like it's out there
especially nowadays people have no idea
you know the other night in front of the
cellar
uh someone went up to young girls online
and said do you know the comic that's on
stage right now dave chappelle and they
said who's that wow yeah it's kind of so
i've heard i've heard young kids be like
oh i don't know what wutang is it's
starting to become like gremlins two
might be so buried in netflix's world
you know i mean like people don't know
it gremlins one is a christmas movie
right to me yeah christmas movie ground
let's do we shoot by the client the
clamp building oh yeah we shoot in the
office around there all the time and i
park at the clamp building and i always
get excited when i do it
like how at the end that [ __ ] thing
came out of the ground and he just
walked out uh clamp i love grinding why
did those fun movies die i need to
re-watch that oh so
david's saying they were going to make
another gremlins for years and years and
years
cartoon now um yeah secrets
of course especially while what's his
name still alive not cgi either
you know
not cgi like what are they doing they're
doing another movie now again oh well
well they might do ralph again and it
was going to be cgi or a puppet no that
would be puppet yeah they're doing alf
they wanted they're rebooting alph how
great is that that's awesome yeah did it
only run two seasons originally four and
four okay yeah plus
two animated series and uh the movie
they'll wrap it all up wow
movie was published they did a no it's
made for tv movie but they showed it
yeah yeah it was like a long episode it
was a lo well no it was made as a movie
it was like it was that's it
project alph
where like the the alien the government
was trying to get him or something like
that
i don't know if i remember that but i
remember the ending where like the
spaceship was coming down to get him i
yes and and project golf picks up on
that thread like alf doesn't get his
credit for the whole alien genre really
existing he's a fun e.t
it's crazy that alf is not more popular
i agree or there hasn't been a while
yeah it was these it was like
took over the world when he was out for
us for kids anyway and actually adults
liked it too is for both him and ernest
put up numbers in the night yes man come
on that first earnest movie is so good
uh ernest goes to camp right
i remember being obsessed with that when
i was a kid and then they went to africa
yeah then he just said oh we gotta watch
her and this goes to africa oh holy [ __ ]
how many faux pas do you think are you
oh my god this is luigi
ernest scared stupid ernie i know that
was earnest goes to jail right ernest it
was earnest goes to camp was the first
one right then ernest goes to jail
ernest saves christmas yeah
uh we should go on his character again
was it mr bean
he passed away too this guy yeah barney
right what was his bit he was just
clumsy i forget no i think i first saw
him in a commercial that's what he
started and then it like yanked it and
made it what was the commercial yeah
what was the commercial for remember
well
god
ernest goes to africa is so ill
it was shot in africa no
look at that
the film was shot entirely in south
africa
wow so he went for a certain cultural
reality wow
yeah i mean what's the plot
while attempting to fix a woman's car at
a local garage we got to find out what
movie he was in as well i mean what
commercial campaign while attempting to
fix a woman's car at a local garage
ernest p warrell accidentally causes the
car to get crushed which results in his
termination he goes to a local
restaurant and asks for his
and asked his crush renee loomis to go
on a date with him he is turned down by
her because she wants to date somebody
more adventurous
um
ernest decides to buy her a gift to show
her that he really cares for her he goes
to a flea market where he buys two
jewels unaware that they are eyes of the
egoli stolen from the sin katutu tribe
in africa by a run runaway named mr
rabbas who is being chased by two
henchmen of prince khazim he is cornered
by the men but rescued by a man named
thompson and his strong african
bodyguard bazoo this is
wild i i cannot believe this is the plot
of an earnest this is all over the place
like just just that plot is like what
and the budget was 900k
wow they shot in africa on less than a
million
how is that
threatening to kill him if he does not
tell him so
ernest's ordeal is just he's just like
blubbering
lovable blubbering he fumbles into
problems
yeah yeah nice guy wow i i mean there's
got to be so many things like ooh that
didn't that didn't age well in that
movie there are but i bet you that his
today's day and age even the poster for
it i'm wearing that mask
at least
i mean there's really not a character
like ernest anymore right well we've
deleted
like mr magoo
yeah but that that ended in the 90s no
but like live action yeah
what if you and i went to medea i don't
know
no but she's not that she's not not that
but but it's an example of a character
driven like they're making movies based
around the fictional character which is
kind of cool james varney so he died oh
wow at this point he died 22 years he's
got like cancer or something right
um
what if we went to warner brothers oh he
died at 50 yeah i think he died of
cancer
cancer we go to warner brothers right
and we're like look we want to create
two characters of the of the earnest
thing for you and i to do and just be
like we'll make like two million dollar
[ __ ] movies you know what i mean and
just do like that sort of thing but who
was this audience because back then i
was this old right but
this audience was for kids but was it
also for grown-ups potheads yeah i think
as it went along like they started
leaning into that sort of thing but this
now i don't know if that it has to be
the version of whatever that is now but
i don't know
who's who does it who's it for if we do
it like adult swim
just for us you think that's adult swim
i don't think that's that that's keen
because he's not making fun of himself
in that genre it's sincere which is why
ernest worked like we'd have to either
care enough to do it sincerely right but
sincerely as we already know because i
think yeah
i don't know man how about this
how come we haven't done a movie like
impractical jokers meets frankenstein or
or something like that like how come
like we we've talked about it over the
years where it's just like didn't we we
talked about that idea now yeah or did
we not i think we we talked about well
definitely not too recently i won a
podcast no not too recently we were
discussing like if we did a movie again
yeah
oh i wanted to do a hidden camera erotic
thriller oh yeah
[Laughter]
i got i was [ __ ] super high one night
and i started texting him and i was like
what about like a hidden camera erotic
thriller like nobody i love the idea i
absolutely love it i love it i i think
that i think that we should put a bunch
of
wild ideas together like this is one
last one and then just bring it to me
like pick one but us meeting like like
me like the old adam and costello like
yeah it would be so funny man i'd love
it i was talking to nick about it when
he was in town we were like what like
just that says in practical jobs meet
frankenstein practical jokers
[ __ ] i don't like you know what i
mean like
costello is so i mean they're genius
it's like it's so hard to you we don't
want to do it like
impression of that right it's like
well you want to do it in the spirit of
it you don't want to rip it up but like
that's the idea like we're playing
ourselves
like i think the plot of that movie was
like dracula shipped frankenstein to the
united states and like having castello
opened it by accident and that was it um
oh i forgot he was in toy story what was
his uh
guys i love doordash uh doordasher came
to my life only a couple of years ago
and i think it's the best thing ever
because for places in my town and near
my near my hood that do not deliver i'd
either have to go there for takeout or
go there to eat and now with doordash
those things are delivered right to my
door i utilize it all the time you know
when i don't want to cook i'm just like
what do i want to get usually i have to
go in my drawer and i have to look up
what menus i have sitting there and
order from like the same five or six
places doordash i download the app i put
in my zip and all of a sudden there are
50 to 60 places that will deliver food
it opens up a whole new world what do
you want to eat tonight maybe you want a
home-cooked favorite but you don't feel
like going to the store or you want
something exciting and new but it'd be a
great just it would be great to just
stay in that's another thing when you
don't want to go out door dish connects
you with everything you want whenever
and however you want it
get what you want to eat right now right
to your door with doordash along with
the restaurants you love you can now get
groceries which i haven't tried yet but
i can't wait and other essential items
delivered with doordash you can drink
snacks and other household items in
under an hour okay
craving late night ice cream forgot the
one key ingredient for dinner this thing
will save you okay or maybe you just
want to stock up for something during
the week you can all do it you can do it
on on the app with everything there's
300 000 partners uh you can support your
neighborhood go to's or choose from
national restaurants too they have like
things like popeyes cheesecake factory
even chipotle on there ordering is easy
and your items will be left safely
outside your door uh when you choose
contactless delivery drop off for a
limited time our listeners can get 25
off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app and enter code
hey babe so that's 25 off up to 10 bucks
in value and zero delivery fees on your
first order so get that first meal out
of the way when you download the
doordash app in the app store and enter
code hey babe don't forget that's code
hey babe for 25 off your first order
with door jash subject to change terms
apply
kitties let's talk about coinbase
because chrissy d loves this thing he
got into crypto recently i have not yet
but i want to and i'm nervous and i
think coinbase is kind of a
user-friendly thing that i can dip a toe
in with do you identify like me as
cryptocurious if you've ever thought
about entering the world of
cryptocurrency but you felt overwhelmed
coinbase makes learning to buy and sell
pretty simple coinbase offers a trusted
and easy to use platform you can buy
sell and spend your cryptocurrency on it
they support the most popular digital
currencies on the market so all those
ones that you know all your faves are
all compatible with coinbase and they
make them accessible to everyone they
offer portfolio management and
protection they offer learning resources
and a mobile app so you can trade secret
securely and monitor your crypto all in
one place right there on your phone
millions of people in over a hundred
countries trust coinbase with their
digital assets man i got to get on board
with this millions of people over 100
countries
i'm crypto curious and i think i'm gonna
i think i'm gonna take the knife whether
you're looking to diversify like we said
or just getting started or searching for
a better way to use an access to crypto
markets start today with coinbase so for
a limited time of course new users can
get ten dollars in free bitcoin when you
sign up today at coinbase.com hey babe
sign up at
coinbase.com
hey babe for 10 bucks in free bitcoin
which if there's any indicator i should
have done that 10 years ago i could have
been living on on on the moon right now
with the money i made the offer is
limited for a limited time only so be
sure to sign up today you know it it's
coinbase.com hey babe
yeah let's see what that is but let's
see what that guy's commercial came from
i think it was if we can guess what do
you think it was was it like was it a
food product or was it like that you
would have been like like a hardware
store yeah right yeah
he's big on that he's almost like do you
know who mike mike rowe is of course
yeah i [ __ ] love mike yeah i i he's
show restarted again i couldn't be
happier he reminds me of like a comedic
micro but if you watch mike rowe
he's the comedic micro i don't know why
that guy's not a [ __ ] he should be in
movies okay i love that guy collection
of advertising from 83 to 2000. wait so
did he create a character that multiple
brands used to advertise so he was
already a character and they hired his
character to be a brand ambassador so
i didn't know that at all oh my god his
last words
oh man
interesting thing to say
yeah i don't think everyone i don't
think everyone gets last words no
because you never know you never know
that they're going to be your last wife
wow
that's that's a downer yeah i know so
what what were the commercials
let's see i'm trying to find
there's like a catalog of them for some
reason
[Music]
no
well it's in the wikipedia doesn't just
say no it didn't say commercials on
there
like the carry there's got to be a
wikipedia for the character right
earnest
hey vern it's earnest was a tv series
yeah but that didn't come first ernest
goes to camp was the first one
it grows 23 million in 1987. he was go
up go i'm sorry but there was there he
was uh he rep all right earned a
commercial for convenient food mark
during the 80s
oh god convenient flour i worked there
for five years get out of here yeah from
14 to 19 years old [ __ ] was your
convenient food marker there still is
the one i worked in is still there with
the orange sign
no he's doing commercials all over he's
doing local spots
so vern was his thing he's like you can
come and get me and vern to do to do
your your comments but there was no vern
right there was no vern he was always
just talk to her yeah hey vern yeah
yeah so was he a comic
it said he was a comedian at the top
okay i remember seeing ernest goes to
camp with my cousin kevin at the at the
ua on staten island and just [ __ ]
loving it i think it was like the
greatest thing of all time you don't
know what i mean google go up a little
bit he says his catchphrase was
no a little bit higher
there's something that said it's catch
for yeah a little higher
right there know what know what i mean
know what i mean burn no one remember
at this point in 1980 his first
commercial featuring the character
advertising appearance by the dallas
cowboys cheerleader cheerleaders
in an amusement park in bowling green
kentucky wow
to go from local commercials of going
yard i mean vern to eight movies yeah he
was a cultural phenomenon i wonder what
his uh
his uh net worth was
at
at that time
i mean if he's making part
seven for less than a million dollars
probably not you know he's probably
right right right oh right the movie
itself right is that a picture of him
that can't be a picture oh my god is
that him that oh that doesn't even look
like he's so thin does that was that him
i don't know that can't be that's that's
just not him
end of life what a depressing thing to
write bud
jim varney uh that's not him
oh that's all right so go up a little
bit that's him when he was older
wow
he looks cool still i think it said 12
million dollars it did say 12.
he did commercials and stuff like that
that's a lot of money that's i mean
that's when he passed 22 years ago
12 million 22 years ago today what is it
12 million dollars in 2000 in the year
2000.
wait 12 million dollars today is worth
12 million dollars
stoner yeah
25 million wow
that's a [ __ ] hell of a lot of money
that's a lot of money dude if i had 25
million dollars i wouldn't be worried
about anything
yeah
no i wouldn't be worried about anything
but they do say like the more you make
the more like you you jab to that
lifestyle than you know succession had
the best line about money where uh
what's his name uh the best guy tom
tom
greg came in to five million dollars and
he's like craig he's like that's the
worst rich he goes you're too rich to
care about working but not rich enough
to stop working and i was like oh my god
that's so depressing i was like five
million dollars isn't enough when did
when did greg come into five million for
his grandfather it was like yeah it was
something to do with the he and he ca
and he got it i didn't know that he
capitalized on five lanes there was some
offer he got yeah where he got five
million and and like tom just ripped it
down he's like it's the worst type
remember there was a scene in in uh
where they were talking to
kendall and they were gonna buy him out
he's like just take the youtube bill and
just you know and they said two billion
like it was nothing and i didn't have a
general i knew that they were like
massive because they're based on yeah i
knew they were bill like the family
maybe had a net worth but the way they
threw around 2 billion you were like oh
my god that was like tube like go away
money and it was like an annoyance to
him yeah i'm not taking that in regards
to billions i'm like woody's the point
what do you mean
um
we're about like 40 minutes 45 minutes
okay you gotta go a little further so i
actually did want to tell you about a
show i started watching last night ryan
suggested it to me and you might have
heard of it it's an apple original
it's
ben siller is the director and
co-executive producer he's texting me
about this and uh i forget the name of
the guy severance is it like you're
you're talking like it's like emily in
paris good i i i watched last night the
first two episodes yeah i'm
all in really i can't wait till like i
get home tonight from where i gotta go
so i go watch another episode it is
so far so really really really i don't
know anything about it i didn't either
yeah so you could watch it cold oh man
the plot sounds crazy i know i watched
scott out of scott
he's great man i never saw a party down
oh
everybody's like you gotta watch parties
right now it's so funny yeah i know
johnson's like excited about because
there's something about a commercial in
it where people keep trying to make him
say commercial he did when he was a
little kid yeah i think he was just
something yeah and now he does parties
um yeah it's good it's just about uh
bartenders for hire that work like
yeah like little parties they're like
bartenders for hire whatever like
they're in a catering company i gotta
get into that i'll work my way through
emily and then i'll jump into severance
so severance no spoilers uh i because i
i you still don't know what i'm doing
yeah i mean but even me like you i still
don't have a full handle on what it's
about but uh the general concept which
you understand nearly immediately it's
not like a
spoiler is
that
they
sign over
the the uh the permission
for them to undergo a
a thing for surgery i guess
where
they sever
their work life in their home life oh
wow and you they don't remember they
they will not remember what's going on
in each okay so
they report to work
and then the transformation happens and
they go into work
and then they don't even know
right necessarily what they're doing
oh all right and that's pretty when they
but when they come out of work they go
back into their real life and they have
no idea what's going on in their work
life and they call they call like the
innies and the audis their audi self is
living life and their any self is in
work wow
i have a hundred theories within two
episodes
but there's so it's like that you're
like oh it's one of those ones where
you're like i bet you
this is this you don't know what their
job is you don't know what their job is
not yet it's it's
it's i think it's alluded to that well i
don't want to give anything away okay if
you found out that that was going i
actually wrote a script when i was um
20 or 22. that was about a guy it was i
think i wrote it with kevin james of
mine and he's like a kind of like a
schlubby dude no offense to kevin james
and he and he found out that like i
guess now you would cast he was
the hidden he was where
james bond went to hide when he wasn't
being james bond so the government had a
button
that they hit
and basically
he would turn into like chris pine
and he would go and he would be a super
secret agent but something went wrong in
the procedure and
he
they pressed the button and he didn't
turn from kevin james to chris pine he
saw chris pine he was the only one that
could see him so he was like a ghost
but he wouldn't transform but he had
access to chris pine's personality in
another person so the government was
like well you're the only one like chris
pines the only one that can defeat this
guy so it's about kevin james and chris
pine whoever was at the time going on
this like james bond mission and like
the whole time it's just chris pine
telling him how to be a spy and it was
like a buddy
as a broad comedy yeah it was a buddy
comedy i wrote the whole script i gotta
find it somewhere yeah yeah um so it
sounds like that sort of kind of thing
is that unfortunately this show this
show came out it is that with no uh
ghost
right well the ghost is the thing oh is
that zachary yeah
oh yeah yeah i remember him at that age
so yeah we met him back then when he was
on chuck we met him yeah he was dancing
on stage we walked into a party at the
comic-cons oh and he recognized i wasn't
there i i you guys went to joe i spoke
to him and he like waited
and then years later like two years ago
he was shazam and he was on mrs maisel
and he we did a we had to do some promo
work with him and met him again really
cool guy so nice dude i love chuck he
was going to start up his whole movie
company right he moved to texas yeah he
said he's thomas he bought like a farm
in texas
acres in texas actually uh i was in
toronto um
filming
what we do in the shadows yeah i wonder
when that's coming out but and i was
walking the streets alone and i passed
by a restaurant that had the front
windows open yeah and people were dying
and he was sitting in at the at the
table right in front of me
yeah and i was like oh my god and i was
like was that him so i stopped and
walked back and maybe i was on my phone
yeah and um
and i looked and it was just him sitting
there eating oh you didn't say hi
no
no no he was with other people i was
gonna be like hey i'm if you don't ruin
me i'm like
but
i just wanted because chuck he he
downloaded this [ __ ] into his brain
right like he didn't the government
tried to do something it didn't go right
and he was stuck with it and he was the
only access point of the data
right but it's not the same it's not the
same i love chuck i never put that in my
head together yeah oh that's funny
with uh the severance it's dude i'm
telling you like watch it immediately
yeah all right yeah it's so would you
guys sign up for that like a separate
mind for work and well here's the thing
no like i said you don't really
understand the implications by me just
telling you because i that's all i knew
about it when i started watching just
that one fact and in my head i
immediately immediately projected it to
be something different it's it's like
it's like kind of like a mystery
kind of really cool like it's almost
like a sci-fi mystery
but when you get to work you have no
idea who you are outside of work you
don't know if you're married if you're
poor if you're rich where you lit you
don't know anything and you could you
only can like wonder what your outside
self is like
but is it that thing where you're like
because you know how like when
you ever think about [ __ ] you've said
while drunk or something like that or
you've been in a situation like
the older i get the more and i when i
was young i would say stupid [ __ ] when i
was drunk but like as i get older i i
grew more of trust in myself where the
next day it would be like oh what the
[ __ ] did i say last night and then i
would be like i ain't insane i know me i
didn't say anything that bad i wonder if
like
would i have faith because the immediate
concern would be like you're doing
something horrible for a living right
well because when you sign up for in the
real world yeah you it's seek secretive
what you're doing in there people don't
know and so like there is a contingent
of people that think it's unethical to
take the job at this place because you
really don't know what you're signing
over to do so there's that little
component going you have to have faith
in yourself that even divorced of who i
am in this moment that's still me and i
would be unwilling to do things
that were wrong you gotta hurry not like
well they divorce my home life and
suddenly i'm a monster
right but dude yeah exactly but
even just the opening scene it's like
one of those movies the opening scene
you're like whoa like this is cool how's
the fashion is it on point
[Laughter]
i'll tell you the fashion
this is all i care about now when it
comes to fashion in certain places is
somewhat purposely distinct really yeah
and i'm also trying to figure out
there's a i don't want to give any
spoilers away and i don't want to ruin
anything for you yeah but like i would
re-watch the first two episodes with you
wow swear just to sit down and like be
able to say all the stuff that i was
thinking to you
all right because she fell asleep and
also she doesn't like to talk during
stuff yeah yeah i like to pause and be
like see now what do you think's
happening yeah i love phone like because
right love talk about it i don't like
she says talk about it after i do it i'm
gonna forget about it i'm gonna forget
about everything after i want to talk
right now in anticipation of what i
think and see if i'm right or not it's
part of the fun it's part of the fun
yeah i've been in relationships i've
been i've been i've gotten complaints
about the pausing yeah i don't know i'm
just like i'm like i'll go like if i
pause it she's like oh come on but i'm
like would you mind pausing for a second
okay and then she'll be like
she'll pause it like what and i go i'll
either be like what do you think well
let me tell you what i think this is and
then she's like
then we start again but then every once
in a while when she wants to say
something like what are you doing
you're going against your own thing here
you're paul you're pausing
love is a battle
[Laughter]
uh oh yeah so that was that was good we
had a little filling up uh you i think
you're gonna be back next week or
possibly again soon yeah because we're
going to record one more
uh where that falls in the in the you
know in a release date we don't know but
um
yeah any any uh anything you want to
plug at all or anything like that no you
know just uh you know tell him steve
dave and uh i i tell him steve davis
your podcast podcast yeah i always
assume people know i guess but uh i i've
been doing for two years i realized the
last time i was like why don't i ever
mention that but i've been doing a radio
show for like two years now on on maker
park radio remember tom ferry we went to
high school with tom ferry yeah so him
and his wife started a non-profit
internet radio station and about two
years ago i started doing like a weekly
show with them i've since kicked it down
to the first monday of every month just
because i scheduled a weekly show with
who just myself it's just music oh well
you should do it with him oh no with
them on maker park radio yes
music yeah it's just it's like a
straight up dj thing you got to do it
live
no you can do it live if you want to do
it from the studio but i find that it
doesn't work for us so i'll just record
i'll record it in real time
uh listen to the songs and everything
and then just send them but what are you
recording
just dj [ __ ] man no no i mean like
your music songs coming from where my
computer oh so it's digital file it's
digital so you're loading just kind of
like almost like a playlist but you're
playing it yeah but you don't mix do you
speak yeah i'll do it it's like
it's like old-school like terrestrial
radios and that's it
i'm just doing the bumpers or like i'll
talk about it so you're like that was
followed by tom petty that was off to
1972.
i don't really do that but yeah that my
version which is more like oh big happy
birthday
um yeah and i've been doing that uh and
now it's the first one they've ever seen
so what are the kind of things you say
in between the songs i'll talk about the
song
or or whatever that song okay so you
don't you don't have to know about the
or are you actually pulling up the wiki
of this song and being like oh this is
sold 100 million okay no you know me i
don't like putting much preparation
right so yeah so when you say you talk
about it it's just yeah on this surface
level this is why like like this is why
i like that song i'll talk like like a
show i did like i went to visit my
parents in the villages which is like
this giant retirement community florida
and i just kept the list of all the
songs that i heard was down there so
that show was like well these are songs
i heard in a retirement community in
florida that's fun yeah and i would just
talk about where i was when i heard it
and and who was listening to this song
so it's like you know every show is two
hours that's a lot of songs that's a lot
of songs it's a lot that's why i went to
once a month because it was like doing
whatever i did every week for a while
well how do you listen
uh go to it's on the internet just make
a park radio maker maker yeah
yeah this is radio and they do
are you archived oh yeah you can listen
to uh also it's called the rnh beer
radio because what happened was the beer
company used to have a radio show in new
york city so i brought it back they
already had a radio program for that but
i'm thinking
you know
yeah so there you go so i that's i
figured you know it might give them a
bump to because they're non-profit you
could play whatever song you want on it
because it's a non-profit oh
how do you get listenership
well for me it's just
just post it but people listen to the
radius like people just put it on all
day and just listen from show to show to
show that's neat yeah it's a lot of fun
like like they got some people who are
better than me are way way better than
me on there but uh that's cool maker
park radio check that out radio so every
first monday the rnh beer radio program
very good uh well two things one uh come
see me at the beacon theater on may 14th
in new york city uh that's a big one
it's a big one uh some surprise guests
gonna be uh coming out is that me and
well no but you can come too okay cool
i mean
all the more better oh
there's a couple of surprise guys
hitting the stage
uh they wanted me they wanted me to keep
it a surprise
but uh but but
i'm gonna keep it surprised until i
think it shouldn't be anymore maybe then
they're gonna take it soon
it's selling really well it's getting it
it's uh so it's gonna sell out they say
so yeah i i uh so it should be fine but
we were like should we really push and
try to do like two i don't think i'm
gonna do two i don't want that pressure
you know but yeah anyway may 14th at the
beacon may 21st uh in san diego and may
22nd in los angeles at the wilton
theater those are big i don't know when
this is coming out uh but uh if it if
it's not april 15th and 16th yet
louisville and evansville and april 23rd
and 24th oklahoma city and tulsa and
then the merch is out and i don't know
when this is coming out either but you
go to my website at savile
countercounty.com and you go to the
store and that'll be a link to all my
solo stuff and then the podcast stuff if
it's out now too uh taste buds and hey
babe and uh yeah that's great this has
been a babe hey babe
flake don't um away from your feelings
babe don't be afraid don't be ashamed
don't hesitate to say hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe hey